MYLES BORINS: Hi.
I'm Myles Borins,
developer advocate
for Google Cloud
Platform and one
of the maintainers of Node.js.
I hear you're interested
in deploying a Node.js
application, so I
want to introduce you
to an amazing product offering
available on Google Cloud
Platform.
Node.js on App Engine
Standard is a great way
to quickly get your application
or service into the cloud.
Take your Node project,
sprinkle a little bit of YAML,
run the magic command,
Gcloud App Deploy,
and you're ready to go.
To demonstrate just how quickly
you can get your code up
and running, I'm
going to highlight
some of my favorite features
of App Engine Standard
while deploying.
So here we have
our package.json.
It's for our Hello
World application.
You could see that our
only dependency is express.
Here is the server.js file.
We create a single route that
always responds, Hello Node.js,
and we listen on
the default port.
Last but not least, we sprinkle
a tiny bit of YAML to taste.
The only thing remaining is to
run the magic command, Gcloud
App Deploy.
So let's a the terminal up,
and a timer, and let's go.
First off, you're going to
notice that the code you write
is idiomatic.
There's nothing special or
magic about writing code
for App Engine.
One of my favorite features
for App Engine Standard
is scale to zero.
You only pay for
the compute you use.
We manage the runtime for you.
When the operating system
or node get an update,
you're going to get
it automagically.
We also install all
the dependencies
in the cloud for you
prior to deployment,
so you can be guaranteed that
your application's running
in a safe sandbox.
Logging, introspection,
live debugging, monitoring--
you get all of that
out-of-the-box.
Want HTTPS?
We got you.
We automate the process
of generating certificates
for default or custom domains.
Well, looks like our
app is already deployed,
so let's pop open a
browser and take a look.
So there you have it, deploying
Node.js to App Engine Standard
with just three magic words--
Gcloud App Deploy.
[CHEERS]
Thanks for joining us today.
I'm Myles Borins.
Please feel free to post
any questions in the comment
section, or ping me on
Twitter at @MylesBorins.